it is my very sad duty to update this
afternoon
police officers searching a wooded area
close to where Constance and Mark Gordon
were arrested discovered the remains of
a baby
a post-mortem examination will be held
in due course
a crime scene is in place and work at
the location is expected to continue for
some time
this is an outcome that myself and that
many officers who have been part of this
search had hoped would not happen
I recognize the impact this news will
have on the many people who have been
following the story closely
and can assure them that we will do
everything we possibly can to establish
what has happened
Constance Martin
and Mark Gordon remain in custody after
the application for the extension of
their detention for a further 36 hours
was sought and granted by Brighton
magistrates Court
it's imperative now that the media and
members of the public refrain from
speculation and comments online that
could be prejudicial to the potential
Court proceedings
no further information about the
discovery will be shared at this time
I ask again that anyone with information
that could support the investigation
should call the instant room on 0208 345
-3854
I'd just like to thank the media the
public and our policing colleagues in
Sussex for their continued support
I would first and foremost like to
extend my heartfelt condolences on
behalf of Sussex police to The Wider
family of the baby at this time
I understand that the conclusion of this
search will be heartbreaking for the
local community and The Wider public
who have been impacted by and so
supportive of this search and the
investigation from the outset
I would like to thank again the public
including the member of public whose
information led to the arrests the huge
number of people who came forward with
information
and those that have volunteered to
assist with the searches
we continue to support the Metropolitan
Police as they conduct their
investigation and also the wider
Community as we all come to terms with
this tragedy
thank you very much everyone
thank you very much
an update there from Sussex police uh
saying that they are delivering of
course the very sad news that they have
found the remains of a baby uh of the
Constance Martin and Mark Gordon were
arrested detectives had feared that the
baby which was missing may have come to
Serious harm as They carried out an
enormous search of the baby which was
just two months
old uh and of course as we have now just
heard the police have found the remains
of that baby having searched a huge area
in the last two days now we can cross
live to our correspondent Adele Robinson
uh who is there in Lewis for us hello to
You Adele Uh certainly uh it was the
news that many dreaded uh what more can
you tell us from what you heard just now
at that press conference
yeah well it was um the news that no one
wanted to hear but everyone was fearing
the police confirming that they have
found the remains of a baby in a wooded
area near to where the couple were
arrested on Monday night in Brighton
they were arrested at 9 30 p.m after a
member of the public who was thanked
here today by the police spotted them in
a nearby shop and we believe followed
them and dialed 999. today we've seen
extensive searches this second day of
searches less than 48 hours since the
couple were arrested into the wider area
the nearby Golf Course the allotments
near to where they were arrested and a
nature reserve 90 square miles was the
vast search area that police officers
from Sussex police and the Metropolitan
Police Service had concentrated their
efforts as I said we've had confirmation
that they have found the remains of a
baby and would area they say that a
crime scene is now in place and will be
in place for some time ahead
this is the outcome as they said that
they did not want to see happen the
police officers here tonight describing
it as heartbreaking
sending out their condolences to The
Wider family of that baby and also
saying that they were going to be doing
a promise if you like to do everything
they can to to understand and find out
what happened to that baby what had led
to its death they also said that their
application to a magistrate in Brighton
earlier today for extra time to question
the couple Constance Martin and Mark
Gordon an extra 36 hours had been
granted they are currently being
questioned on suspicion of gross
negligence manslaughter remember they
were first arrested at 9 30 p.m on
Monday night on suspicion of child
neglect a day later yesterday that
charge
or that they were arrested on on
suspicion of was upgraded to gross
negligence manslaughter
what they did ask was for the public and
the media not to speculate on what may
have happened in this case not wanting
to Prejudice any future proceedings
um but they did thank the media and the
public as well for the huge efforts that
the public have made to get in touch
with information as I said they thanked
the member of the public who had spotted
the couple on Monday night and dialed
999 leading to their arrest
and
um they also said that
um that crime scene again would be
remaining in place for some time to come
um the search we've seen over the last
less than 48 hours has been as described
earlier painstating painstaking
complicated difficult challenging
um we haven't seen this cup of the
couple for over 50 days the
investigation started in in Bolton
um and as we have it is ended now in the
discovery of the couple and that
heartbreaking news that their baby has
been found the remains of their baby has
been found in wooded area in Brighton so
the investigation continues and this
evening the couple remain in custody
okay uh Adele Robinson uh there for us
in Lewis and for anyone just tuning in
um we are reacting uh to the news that
we've just had uh from Sussex police uh
that a bit the remains of a baby has
been found after Constance Martin and
her partner Mark Gordon uh were arrested
earlier this week having uh been missing
essentially since January uh when the
couple had been found uh on the Run
essentially with a newborn baby causing
a lot of uh concern and now this news
from the police for anyone tuning in
Adele could you just
um actually we're not going to cross
back to Adele we're just going to keep
you updated on this uh breaking news
that police
have found the remains of a baby uh
describing it as their very sad duty to
make this update this afternoon that
police officers searching a wooded area
close to where Constance
Martin and Mark Gordon were arrested
they have now discovered the remains of
a baby after a huge search being carried
out by police officers we can now bring
in Skye's uh policing analyst Graham
wetton who's been following this case
for us uh good to have you with us for
your analysis and expertise Graham uh
what do you make of this announcement
from the police in the last few minutes
of course they've been carrying out an
enormous search in the last couple of
days but we don't really know much more
about what's happened to this baby in
the last couple of months other than the
fact that we now know the remains of the
baby has been found
yeah they said it was going to be a
significant um press conference and they
announced that a body had been found by
police searching in the areas they've
been looking in
um specialist crime commands from from
the Metropolitan Police will now lead on
this uh AB supported by their colleagues
down in Sussex so they're very well
versed and experienced in dealing with
with manslaughter type cases crime scene
will be in place where the body was
found that probably will stay where they
found it for now what I clear the crime
scene pick up you know forensically
examine the scene itself take away
anything that there might be evidence
from the crime scene but that will stay
in place for some time uh in that outer
called maybe a route in for the forensic
seams so you'll see that sort of
activity around the location where the
body was found
um postwater will be carried out to
establish the cause of death and then
from there the investigation team will
take their inquiries onwards
uh yeah and Graham you know this is an
extraordinary case uh that this uh
couple have been essentially on the run
for a couple of months now it's taken a
long time for all the police and
authorities to track them down and of
course the huge concern was that they
had this newborn baby with them and the
welfare of the baby was of course
everyone's uh concern mostly um constant
Martin's Family who of course have
spoken out and appealed to her
um what now what now how what will
police be doing in terms of trying to
piece together what's happened in the
last two months
but it's exactly that to be trying to
piece together exactly what happened the
couple's movements that we I think we
saw that they were last sighted early
January so again that's partly appeal
that was just out uh still appealing for
any information that can Aid the
investigation the investigation is
around where they've been in the last um
seven weeks or so where they've been
staying where they've been getting their
food uh was it just the couple was it
the couple and the baby that's all quite
the investigation now to establish a
timeline of where the couple have been
and where the baby's been with them
um you know how when when the baby was
was either shopping with them or going
getting taxi rides or bus rides Etc
that's partly information that the
investigation team will be after to
establish an exact timeline of where the
couple have been and what they've been
doing
okay Graham as always it's very good to
get your Insight on these sorts of cases
thanks very much indeed we can just
cross back to our correspondent Adele
Robinson who is following developments
uh for us today down in Sussex for
anyone just tuning in Adele can you just
bring us up to date
yes just to summarize what the police
have announced this evening as they
described it heartbreaking news
um at the center of their investigation
has always been to find this missing
baby and now
it has been found the remains in wooded
area the news that nobody wanted to hear
but over the last couple of days
everyone was fearing
um weren't they it's the sad Duty the
police officer said tonight from the
Metro Metropolitan Police to inform
everybody that they had found these
remains in wooded area near to where the
couple Constance Martin and Mark Gordon
went missing in Brighton at 9 30 p.m on
Monday evening after a member of the
public spotted them in a nearby shop and
followed them he then called 999 and
that member of the public was
specifically thanked publicly by both
police officers here outside Sussex
police headquarters for what he did
leading to their arrest they were
originally arrested on suspicion of
child neglect yesterday
they were re-arrested on suspicion of
gross negligence manslaughter now
yesterday the police also told us that
the couple hadn't offered any
information as to the whereabouts of
their child we didn't even know the
gender of this missing baby
they said that the couple are still in
custody this evening they had made an
application to a magistrate in Brighton
today to question the couple on
suspicion of gross negligence
manslaughter for an extra 36 hours and
that has been granted so they are still
in custody
the police said that they will do
everything they can to find out what
happened to this baby to understand what
happened
they said that they were asking the
public and the media not to get involved
in any speculation as to what would as
to what happened to the baby
in case it prejudiced any future
proceedings but they also thanked the
media and the public for the huge effort
that was made to get in touch with the
police with their with information that
they have and also because we've seen
over the last couple of days huge public
appeals going out this is an
investigation that really began back on
January the 5th when the couple's car
was found abandoned on the side of the
motorway near Bolton and on fire and it
has taken this investigation across the
country over to Essex where the couple
was spotted in the days immediately
after they went missing and then the day
after on the seventh again East London
and then on the 8th January the 8th the
last confirmed sighting of that couple
was in New Haven
and the police earlier today
stressed the time frame of their
investigation spanned more than seven
weeks their search a vast area 90 square
miles and we've seen today
um
dozens and dozens of specialist officers
scaring the Woodland near to where the
couple went missing they broke into
sheds on the allotments very close by
trying to find the missing baby they
looked on the golf course they were even
seen scouring some water a water a
section of water nearby as well
it has taken 200 officers across two
forces Sussex police and the
metropolitan police force
to bring this investigation to find the
missing baby to a heartbreaking
conclusion and what they will be now
focusing on is questioning the couple
and trying to get to the bottom of
exactly what happened to this baby and
why